et sans changer nécessairement
radicalement pour le consommateur on
veut pas nécessairement revenir à
l'époque où on avait des tomates
seulement l'été peut-être que certains
voudront le faire mais en émettant
l'hypothèse que tout le monde ne fera
pas ça du jour au lendemain mais quand
même des choses qu'on peut faire et
justement par rapport à notre
consommation responsable dans
l'alimentation
il ya eu toute une promotion de
l'agriculture au niveau local qui se
développer au cours des dernières années
et là maintenant les commandes les
consommateurs commencent à se poser la
question entre la tomate qui arrive de
l'autre bout de la planète ou à peu près
et celle produite dans une serre au
québec qu'est ce qui est le mieux
finalement pas de solution plus verte et
cédé juste des solutions moins brillant
c'est parce qu'en peppers on peut pas
dire à sk on privilégie le local où le
bio le geipan dans le détail on
privilégie les deux pions même en mêlée
qui t'as beau milieu de se moquer mais
il arrive toujours un choix même - là
qui va au supermarché où j'ai un
compromis un choix de valeurs à faire
est ce que je vois justement privilégier
l'environnement d'inhumer gaz à effet de
serre acheter local où est ce que je
vais choisir biologique et privilégier
ma valeur sur ma santé parce que je sais
qu'il ya pas de pesticides
ça c'est et puis en europe où il y en
aura pas de bonnes il ya le portefeuille
aussi et ça c'est quelque chose très
intéressant c'est que biologique et tout
le système alimentaire il faut qu'ils se
verdissent il faut qu'il y ait moins
bradé brunet brunet merci et ça c'est
génial plein de belles initiatives à
montréal en région je connais moins à
montréal avec les fruitiers avec des
marchés de quartier il ya plein de
choses levitte quartier qui prennent les
les paniers bio que ça aussi c'est à
l'extérieur de montréal c'est génial
mais d'un autre côté faut juste faire
attention c'est à ce choix de société là
parce que c'est la classe aisée la
classe riche qui peut souvent ce père
médecin et quelque part on est tous est
en train de créer des déserts et d
insécurité alimentaire et de créer les
corps encore plus grand pour les
populations vulnérables ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on n'oublie un petit peu
souvent parce qu'on est des gens engagés
ou qui s'intéressent à la
question mais il ya tout un autre enjeu
pans de la société qu'il faut faire
attention dans cette école qui est de
plus en plus grand parce que manger bio
pour l'instant ça coûte plus cher quand
même